رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي المكلف بنيامين
نتنياهو طلب في رساله الى الرئيس
الاسرائيلي اسحاق هيرتزك تمديد المهله
الممنوحه له لتشكيل الحكومه الجديده 14
يوما المسموح بها بموجب القانون مشيرا الى
تاخر الاتفاق على ادوار شركائه في الاتلاف
كان هيلز جوك اعطى نتنياهو مهله 28 يوما
لتشكيل الحكومه تنتهي يوم الاحد المقبل
حزب لكود الذي يتزحمه نتنياهو قال في بيان
انه توصل الى اتفاق تلاف مع حزب شاس مما
يجعله خامس حسبه ينضم الى نتنياهو ويمنحه
سيطره مريحه على 64 مقعدا في الكنيسات من
اصل 120 مقلقه
بين حزبين كود وشاس على ان يتولى درع زعيم
حزب شاس وزاره الداخليه والصحه خلال النصف
الاول من ولايه الحكومه ثم وزاره الماليه
في النصف الثاني منها كما سيشغل منصب نائب
رئيس الوزراء ولا لا يتينه ياهو المعارضه
المنتميه للوسط حتى ترزج على عدم منح
تمديد لنتنياهو متهمه اياه بانه يحاول ان
يكسب الوقت لاقرار تشريعات مثيره للجدل
وقد يمكن احد مشروعات القوانين هذا اريد
درعي من تقلد منصب وزاري على الرغم من
سجله الجنائي
اودين بالاحتيال الضريبي في السنه الماضيه
لكنه نجا من السجن بموجب اتفاق اقرار
بالذنب انضمامه الى الحكومه الجديده الى
جانب حزبين يمينيين متطرفين يديرهما
مستوطنون متشددين في الضفه الغربيه يثير
القلق في اسرائيل وفي خارجها